Otto von Bismarck is often considered to
be one of the most competent politicians
of the 19th century he's credited with
being the architect of German
unification with the sidelining of
Austria-Hungary in France and with
making Germany into one of the world's
greatest industrial Powers but in spite
of these things two years after Kaiser
Wilhelm II took the throne Bismarck was
out of a job however given bismarck's
reputation this raises the question why
did the Kaiser get rid of him so
Bismarck served all three German
Emperors and he held great Sway With
Wilhelm the first who largely deferred
to Bismarck when it came to the running
of the Empire much of this was down to
them largely agreeing on things like
workers rights foreign relations and
economic policy Bismarck also served as
Chancellor for the entire reign of
Frederick III now Frederick was seen as
a Beacon of Hope by German liberals who
had hoped that under him reforms would
be undertaken to move Germany away from
absolute monarchy to something closer to
Britain or Sweden unfortunately
Frederick died 99 days after becoming
Emperor and so his Reign amounted to
sweep nothing after Frederick came his
son Wilhelm II now Wilhelm had inherited
a Germany which was geopolitically
ascendant but domestic basically there
were issues social unrest especially
about working conditions in mines and
factories were starting to take its toll
on Germany's economy Wilhelm II was
somewhat sympathetic to them but wanted
Parliament to improve their lot however
the Chancellor's plan was to ban
socialists and agitators from German
life and in fact some of the law was so
harsh that some of his backers and the
Kaiser disagreed with them another
problem was that Wilhelm and Bismarck
also had conflicting personalities both
men were proud and had very different
ideas about how to improve Germany's
Prestige and power the Kaiser saw
Bismarck as being a pacifist with an
outdated view of the world whereas
Bismarck didn't respect the Kaiser and
saw him as Russian foolhardy another
reason was simply that Wilhelm II wanted
to be his own Emperor whilst he did
respect bismarck's achievements he
didn't want to be seen like his
grandfather with Bismarck as being the
power behind the throne the Kaiser
didn't want to take a back seat in
governing Germany and one major way in
which philharm could impact things is by
appointing his own Chancellor and not
keeping the one he inherited this wasn't
the first instance in which Bismarck had
been in conflict with the Kaiser but
this time there was a difference in the
past whenever Bismarck and Wilhelm the
first had had a disagreement Bismarck
were threaten to resign he knew the
emperor saw him as Irreplaceable and so
he would always get his way Bismarck had
hoped that in spite of Wilhelm II's
Bluster he would have no choice but to
retain him as Chancellor as such when
filham iI demanded that the government
report directly to him in All matters
and also that Bismarck must give the
Striking miners a better deal Bismarck
threatened to resign to which the
emperor's response was okay nice knowing
you thereby ending his 30-year stint at
the heart of German politics I hope you
enjoyed this episode and thank you for
watching with a special thanks to my
patrons James bisonet Kelly moneymaker
call show wolf katoitska Adam's daughter
Jerry lambdin Jordan Longley Alex
Schwinn Marcus arsner why in hockey
Spencer Lightfoot Marvin cassow Captain
psydog the mcguoper Miss izet Winston k
word commune boogly Wiggly Gustav Swan
Aaron the white Daniel tobian Anthony
Beckett Maggie Paskowski she went in
spinning three plates words about books
podcast Coppertone and Charles the first